- [Instructor] The goal of this video
is to introduce you to the idea
of learning plans on Khan Academy.
And I'm gonna focus on a
plan for sixth grade math.
But what I'm talking
about is as applicable
to fourth grade math as
it is to sixth grade math
as it is to something like
calculus or statistics.
Now the core of any learning plan
is the course you're actually working on.
So if I were to click on
sixth grade math here,
I would go right over here
to the sixth grade course
on Khan Academy.
In order to make sense
of the learning plan,
you really first need to make sense
of how's a course
structured on Khan Academy.
Every course is subdivided into units.
You can see the units
listed on the left here,
Ratios, rates and percentages,
Arithmetic operations, so on and so forth.
You also see them listed
on the right here.
And on the right, they are broken down
into the various lessons.
Now you have two things going on.
You have a certain
number of mastery points
for the entire course
and then you have a certain
number of mastery points
for that unit.
And as we'll see in the learning plan,
we're gonna talk about
how you can pace yourself
through these units and what are some
target mastery point goals you could have
for the units in a given week.
So if we go back to the plan itself,
there's some text that
explains how to do it.
But what it essentially
says is here is the plan
and we give several plans,
one that can occur over 20 weeks
and then another than
can occur over 12 weeks.
And we say week by week
what unit should you be working on,
and then how many mastery points
should you target getting at least.
And there's space for you to write down
or type in, at the end of the week,
how many mastery points did you get,
which you might wanna
share with your parents
or your teacher.
And so if you just keep doing that over,
in this case, those 20 weeks,
then by the end of that you
will have a good understanding
of sixth grade math.
Now, at the end we have something
called the course challenge.
And we also talk about,
earlier in this plan,
that you might wanna start
by taking these course challenges.
So what are we talking about?
Well, if you go to a course,
if you go to the bottom,
you see Course challenge here.
And if I click there,
it's gonna scroll down
right over there and says
Start Course challenge.
And when I start there, it's
going to give me 30 questions
that'll take me 30 to 45 minutes
that are sampling items
from throughout the course.
Given that many of you
have already completed
a good chunk of the school year,
this is a great place to start
because it can give you accelerated credit
for things you already know.
And it can help you understand the things
that you don't know.
The things that you do know,
you'll start going to start
getting leveled up in.
And to understand what it
means to get leveled up,
we can go into this first unit
that I've already started working on,
and you could see skill by skill
it has a sense of
whether you are familiar,
proficient or master,
depending on how many
of these stacked blocks
you actually get.
So if you already know a
lot of a given grade level
or lot of a given course,
I recommend taking the course challenge.
And if you get 70% or better,
take it again and again.
That'll really accelerate
your mastery points
and give you credit for a lot of skills,
so then you can focus on the
ones that you don't know.
And then the ones that you don't know,
you can then go to those particular units
and take the unit test in them.
And just to get a sense of
what the unit tests look like,
let's go this first unit again.
And if you click here in the
bottom left on Unit test,
it'll scroll down at
the bottom of the page
and you could say Start Unit test.
And the unit test, you can kind of view it
as a course challenge that's
just focused on that unit.
So once again if you feel
like you already know
a particular unit, you
could take the unit test
over and over again, you're
gonna get different questions,
and that's a faster way
to get leveled up mastery.
Now going back to sixth grade,
you might have noticed this
thing called Mastery challenge.
A mastery challenge allows
your skills to get leveled up,
and these are skills
that you might have
gotten familiar recently
or they're making sure
that you've reviewed skills
that you've seen in the past.
So going back to the plan,
start with the course challenge
and then the appropriate unit test.
And as much as possible try to keep pace
with these points right over here.
Now for some reason you
fall behind, not a big deal.
And if for some reason, you
feel like jumping around,
that is okay too.
This is all about
helping you, the student,
be in the driver seat
of your own learning.
Now, for those of you who are feeling
a little bit less confident,
we're also providing for each grade level
ways to build your foundations.
So this is what we're calling
the super-ultra-strong
foundation learning plan
for, in this case, students
completing sixth grade.
And there we say,
"Hey in parallel to trying
to finish sixth grade,
"try to do the same thing
with our arithmetic course."
And if you are a sixth grader
taking the arithmetic course,
a lot of it is going to be a review.
So once again, take
those course challenges
as many times as you like.
If you're getting 70% or over,
you're likely to really
be able to accelerate
what you do know and then you'll know
where your gaps are and you
can focus on those units.
Now in each of the plans
for either the grade level
or for the foundational work,
we have both 20-week plans
that I just showed you
and we have a 12-week plan.
The 12-week plan focuses a little bit more
on the essentials of the course
while the 20-week plan is
a bit more comprehensive.
So think about which
one works best for you
and think about whether you
need just the grade level course
or in parallel to do the
foundational work as well.
But either way, all of
us here at Khan Academy
are confident that if you stay focused,
you keep up with these plans,
that over the course of the
school closures in the summer,
you're gonna build a
really strong foundation
in your mathematics,
and you'll be off to a great
start next school year.